I can't tell you right now what things are
going to be like in November.
I can only tell you what things are like right
now.
And right now, Donald Trump and Joe Biden
are.
Seeing a shift in who is supporting them and
older voters are abandoning Donald Trump and
they are flocking to Joe Biden in large numbers.
Why do we care while we care about every vote?
But in particular, we care because older voters
are a key voting group for Donald Trump.
If you look back at the 2016 exit polls, Trump
won voters age 50 or older by the largest
margin.
Trump won voter voters in their 40s by a little
bit, and Trump lost all age groups from thirty
nine and under.
Republicans in general have done better with
older voters than younger voters for a very
long time.
So the important thing is Trump needs older
voters to win in November.
Back in 2016, Trump won voters aged 45 to
64 by 4 percent.
Right now, we've seen a five point swing with
Biden leading that group 45 to 64 by about
one and a half points.
That's a five and a half point reversal from
2016.
Normal caveats.
It's early.
A lot can change when we look at voters 65
plus.
Trump won that group by 13 points in 2016.
He is now losing 65 plus by one point to Biden.
That is a 14 point swing.
Now, why is this happening?
Speculation.
It's speculation right now.
Someone wrote to me and said, David, older
folks are dying from Corona virus and it's
the Trump older folks that are more likely
to die because they're not wearing masks or
staying home.
I understand the logic of that.
It's been floated.
We don't have any evidence for that right
now.
Corona virus in general is the most sort of
obvious explanation.
Older folks are most at risk from Corona virus
and they might react the most strongly to
Donald Trump's mishandling of it.
This problem with older voters that Trump
is having could explain why Trump is not doing
well in states with older populations.
Florida is one such state that's a key state.
Florida's population is the fifth oldest in
the country.
The latest polls have Trump losing to Biden
by 6 in Florida.
More importantly for today's story, Quinnipiac
has Trump losing by 10 in Florida among voters
65 and older.
So I don't want to get anybody's hopes up.
We've got to count every vote.
This is a snapshot right now.
But if Trump loses older voters in Florida
by anything close to 10, even by 6 or 7, it's
over for Trump.
Now, if coronavirus starts to wane, if the
economy recovers or appears to recover and
Trump can attach his name to the recovery,
things could turn around very quickly.
So, you know, when you start slicing and dicing
the electorate in this way, it's really difficult
to glean anything super useful from it.
What I do think is interesting is the following.
We believe that about 13 percent of people
who voted for Obama-Biden and 26 in 2012 voted
for Trump.
In 2016, 13 percent of Obama's twelve voters
went for Trump in 16.
If Biden can get back just half of those people
and not lose anybody that voted for Hillary.
That translates to a 7 million vote victory
in the popular vote for Biden in 2020.
Now, you could win the popular vote by 7 million
and lose the Electoral College.
It's theoretically possible.
We've never seen it.
So now go back and think people who were on
board with Obama in 2012 and voted Trump for
some reason in 2016.
Are they likely to stick with Trump over a
guy they already voted for years prior and
Joe and Joe Biden, if he only gets half of
them back?
It looks very good for Biden.
Again, nothing is guaranteed.
If Biden can win back just half of those voters
who went from Obama in 12 to Trump in 16,
he has a very, very good starting point for
2020.
So what does this mean for us?
Nothing.
All it means is every single one of us needs
to vote.
Remember that on Monday, Memorial Day will
have a huge David Pakman show membership special
get notified on Monday, Memorial Day by signing
up for our newsletter at David Pakman dot
com.
It's quick, it's easy, it's free.
And then Monday you will hear about this incredible
membership discount.
No time for the voicemail.
I'll talk to you on the bonus show today.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.